assalamualaikum greetings of peace walk
up to the D show look who's here with me
after all this time shallow lake oh how
I said I'm good Habibi
I'm very good very nice to see you good
to see you again after so many years I
know I hamdulillah reunited we're gonna
get into this video I'm gonna watch this
video and we're gonna do a reaction to
it our front Tony Robbins and Sharla we
sent him some message some advice with
love let's check it out
Tony a meaningful life by constantly
looking for ways I can be helpful and my
prayer a simple prayer before I walk out
of every stages use me use me Lord and
when you do that it's like if you get
all the way my greatest gift is getting
out of the way I know that sounds silly
to some people but it's really true I'm
not an ultra religious person but I'm
extremely spiritual and I believe the
force of life comes through me it comes
through here comes through all of us and
the only get from the way is all the
beliefs we have of how it's supposed to
be all the expectations we what do you
think I think I mean first of all I have
been listening to this guy for quite a
while he's got some good things to say
huh and he's got a lot of good things to
say I'm very interested in psychology so
it's amazing how he can connect with
people and communicate with them it is a
gift it's a gift from Allah for sure so
yeah I mean I believe that anybody with
a sincere and open heart who looks into
Islam who really looks at it sincerely
with an open heart with no agenda they
will know it's the truth 100% you will
know like you know your son's your son
you're gonna know Islam as the truth
that's what I believe it's interesting
to have him when you hear him say for
obviously he believes in a higher being
in God he says I'm not too religious we
we hear this a lot that I'm not too
religious but I'm spiritual so what do
you think when you hear that I think
people you see in the West people have
very and he should know this language
programs the way we think about language
programs the way we think so when we use
the term religion in the West we are
programmed by our history by our society
by our environment to think okay this is
what religion is and to be honest to be
fair a lot of people would want to
disassociate themselves from that but we
don't you know in Islam we talk about
Dean Wayne show way of
life yeah which is equal Dean shows the
Dean show is a way of life it's a way of
living it is something that encompasses
every aspect of your being right and
another thing that I would say to tony
robbins and anybody who says i'm not
very religious I'm sure he recognizes as
anybody who wants to achieve something
significant in their life they you need
discipline to do that if you want to be
an athlete athletes are extremely
disciplined and you know that Eddy
yourself right how you train how often
you train what you eat what you don't
eat okay
you have to especially before a
competition why is it different when it
comes to spirituality why when it comes
to spirituality we just adopt this lace
a fair approach and I just do whatever I
feel like and how it goes you know like
this way and that why should we not be
disciplined and look at the training I
call Islam a spiritual training program
to help you become a spiritual athlete
we're praying five times a day right
constantly reconnecting ourselves to our
Creator we have this beautiful fasting
in the month of Ramadan we have the
pilgrimage or the charity that we need
to give to the poor people
I'm just giving some basic elements of
Islam but it is a whole system that
encompasses everything in your life that
gives you this beautiful spiritual
connection with Allah there is extremely
deep and extremely extremely profound
another thing that caught my attention
is that he did he say every day he turns
up to the Creator to God he says use me
yeah I mean that's deep I mean what if
you do it what's the difference between
used me and guide me what do you think
cuz we believe honestly that sincerely
that with no shadow of a doubt that if
you asked the Creator alone sincerely
guide me guide me to the way of life
that you want me to live he'll guide you
so what would you what would you what's
your reaction to that I don't want to
overanalyze it too much but I think that
um I imagine that Tony thinks and he has
look he's got a gift he understands
about human psychology he understands
about human beings how they work how
they tick he talks about the essential
needs that human beings have
psychological needs that they have which
is deep stuff so maybe Tony thinks that
he's you know he's got
that stuff you know he's pinned it down
and maybe he feels because his life is
full of purpose maybe he doesn't feel
that he needs guidance maybe he does
feel though that he needs to give that's
what he feels is really missing or what
he the area that he needs fulfillment in
now he'll talk about that himself that
area that needs fulfillment but in
reality I don't know for someone like
Tony in a way it's got to be a moment
that'll happen in his life when he'll
realize wait a minute you know have I
really got this down how do I really
understand all of this and that's the
moment when it happens to you and it
will it's that's the moment I want you
to think about what we're saying here
think about Islam turn open that book
the Koran read it and see what it has to
say cuz the Lord of the heavens and the
earth is gonna speak to you through
those beautiful words one last thing you
know religion in the sense and you
define that misconception you know it's
very important that the way we define
words Deen is a way of life it's a way
of life that's what it's light it's a
complete system a way of life is not
something constricted that you just do
weekly once a week we live it every day
24 hours it's 24/7 we do our best to
submit our will to the Creator the
heavens an urban now religion in and of
itself that's why you see people calling
themselves or spiritual right we're
spiritual and and and and we throw all
religions because all religions are the
same what makes Islam so unique that it
stands out for the rest that it really
amazed you that had you coming from a
Christian background you know that you
ended up except accepting it instead of
people thinking that this is just
another religion with a set of rules and
they're all the same
well how does it stop the rest you know
Eddie that's that that's a super deep
and super important question I'm gonna
be straight up I'm gonna answer it
honestly the difference is this every
religion is going to have elements of
truth in it like almost every religion
will tell you to control your ego right
and control your desires but so every
religion has truth in it there is only
one religion that I could say for sure
is the truth right that is that is the
pure Islam the pure Islam of the Quran
and teachings of the Prophet I don't
mean the stuff that Muslims have mixed
in with it but if you go back to the
core
and you go back to those authentic
sayings of the Prophet there you will
find truth on another different level
and that's the difference you see that's
the difference between Islam and every
other religion the the truth is there as
opposed to bits and pieces of truth
mixed up with other stuff
with the Quran it's clear this is a book
that is
uncorrupted it's preserved and its
message is clear and it is the truth
that's the difference a couple more
important questions please look someone
says I'll just figure it out it's too
confusing I'll just figure it out if
there is a God well I believe in God I'm
doing my best
many people say I'm a good human being I
can decipher what's right right and
wrong God has given me the intelligence
to be able to figure it out and if I'm
wrong God will correct me you know he's
all loving and at the end when I die God
will sort it out well that's true and
it's true from one perspective
everything you said Eddie if the people
say that it's true but that doesn't mean
that you don't there that doesn't mean
that God has not revealed to us truth in
this life
why if Allah has given us food and Allah
has given us clothing and every need
that you have and Tony will understand
this as well he talks about the
fundamental needs the human beings have
and you think that everything a human
being needs physically mentally
spiritually he's given us he's provided
for us and one of the biggest needs we
have the greatest actually that what we
need more than food and anything else
even a human affection and company and
whatever we need guidance guidance we
need that we need the guidance so how
would God give us all of these bounties
and blessings and not provide us clear
guidance so we can look at it and say
this is from God that's the that's the
impact the Quran had on me when I read a
translation of the Quran I said to
myself I have studied most religions on
this earth right and this is the only
one that I can say I'm pretty sure this
is from the creator of that he's a very
smart man he's worth billions do you
think if he took a very sincere
analytical scientific approach he really
he was asking the Creator within himself
to guide him and he sincerely looked at
Islam to the right lenses that he would
come to know that it's from the curry
anyone would any
anyone who approaches the cram with the
open with sincerity with no agenda with
an open heart and they ask God to guide
them to the truth and I'm not saying Oh
God make me a muslim or no God just ask
God guide me to the truth if there is a
right way and there's a true religion
show me it show me it
pick up the Quran you'll know you got
Tony you got his attention what else
you'd like to say Tony Robbins delivery
Rahim green Sheikh go ahead you got him
here I would say Tony you've done great
stuff you're doing great stuff I love
what you say use me I love that just
make the same prayer guide me to the
truth show me the right way if there's a
true religion show me what it is that's
my advice to you very important to know
how we got here why we're here where
we're going when we die well we're going
what's it you know because it's not just
about what we do in this life it's what
what's gonna happen when we die that's
that's one of the biggest questions of
all and these are all psyche can you
look at those if you let's say he Tunes
in yeah that God Almighty sent signs I
mean what kind of coincidence now you
got two muslims sending with love a
message to tony robbins he's got a
really reflecting wow that can god be
sending me signs i mean this would be a
sign for him wouldn't it well i guess so
if he's looking for something something
happens in his life and he just happens
across this eddie's guys that's maybe
that's the sign you're looking for thank
you very much we got a buddy bless you